The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today what
we've been doing,
we've been looking
at how there's
a lot of different
representations for CT systems.
They look almost the same
as a lot of representations
for DT systems.
And today I want
to go one more step
and show how there's actually
a bunch of relationships
between them.
That's when things
become very powerful.
And so I want to
do that by thinking
about a very simple example,
thinking about a CT system
and how you would convert
that CT system into a DT
representation.
This is a problem we've worked
on before, the leaky tank
system.
We've already seen a gazillion
representations for it.
We can think about the leaky
tank system as a differential
equation.
We derive that in Lecture One.
We can think of it as a
block diagram, Lecture One.
We can think about
it as a functional.
That was about two lectures ago.
As a system function, that
was Laplace transforms,
that was about a week ago.
We can think about
an impulse response
because the fundamental
signal in CT,
the thing that plays the same
role as the unit sample in DT,
is the unit impulse.
So we can think about
the impulse response.
And there's a variety
of connections
between all of those.
What I want to do today is
compare the step response
of the leaky tank
system to the step
response of a DT approximation
to the tank system.
To get started then, I want to
figure out the step response
of the leaky tank system.
For you, you should think about
this as practice for the exam.
You should be able to
do this in 30 seconds.
So start.
Compare your answers
to your neighbor.
Figure out what is
the step response
for the leaky tank system.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
No.
OK, this question is too simple
so we're going to blast ahead.
What's the answer?
What's the step response
for the leaky tank system?
Everybody raise your hand.
Let me see how many numbers.
OK, it's not quite as high a
fraction as I would have liked.
Take another 15 seconds.
Or better yet, talk
to your neighbor.
Explain your answer
to your neighbor
and let your neighbor
tell you why you're wrong.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK, re-vote.
So what's the step response
of the leaky tank system?
Better.
Better, better, better,
better, better, better.
OK, almost 100%.
Not quite.
Another question.
How many ways can you find the
step response of the leaky tank
system?
One represents more than one.
I'm not going to have a
representation for 0, right.
More than one, more than
two, more than three,
more than four, more than five.
How many ways can you find that?
Don't just stare at
me with blank looks.
OK, what's a good
way to find the step
response of this system?
You can shout,
that way I won't be
able to identify where
you're coming from
and I won't be able
to point to you.
But you have to be quick because
if I see your mouth move then
I'll know which one you are.
So when I look at it this way
you shout over here, right.
There's simple ways
to do this, right.
What's a good way to find the
step response of the leaky tank
system?
AUDIENCE: You have the transfer
function [? magnetized ?]
with one bias then we
have the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's a
relatively advanced way
and it's completely correct.
Could somebody tell me
an even simpler way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the behavior
as t goes to infinity.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What is it?
Let's do something easier.
What's the input?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
a unit step, right.
So the input is some
unit step thing right.
So my input, if I think
about some input r0 of t,
the input is something
that looks like that.
So if I look at,
like you suggested,
if I look at what's
going to happen for t
goes to infinity,
what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: Eventually the
rate at which we're going out
is going to be the same as
the rate that's going it.
PROFESSOR: So
based on that, do I
like this one, this one, this
one, this one, or that one?
AUDIENCE: So, it knocks
out one and three.
PROFESSOR: Knocks
out one and three
because we're not
expecting it to go
to zero because the
input didn't go to zero.
Good.
OK, so it's maybe
this, or this, or that.
What's a good method?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the
thing that confused
me is that in the original
problem on the problem set
we had it was a
second order system,
but this one's a first order.
PROFESSOR: This is first order.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
then you know that it's
going to look like something's
that's first order.
PROFESSOR: Still looks like
something that's first order.
That's good.
I asked the question here
and I flicked back here,
that was a clue.
How many ways can you think
of to do this problem?
Five ways.
OK.
You could think about solving it
by looking at the differential
equation.
How about how many
of you could do that?
OK, how many of you took 1803?
Ah, good, good.
So all of you could do
it by doing the lower
left-hand corner, right?
OK, you could all
do it that way.
You could all do it with
block diagrams, right.
We thought about how you put
a signal into a block diagram
and you can chase it
around its end, right.
You could do it that way.
So there's at least five ways.
Just as rehearsal, I'm
sharing two ways here
that don't quite fall
there, so my answer would
have been at least seven ways
that I can do this problem.
Because I'm going to
show you two new ones
that don't appear directly.
One way is to think about
the differential equation,
solving for t less than zero
and t greater than zero.
Paste the solutions together.
With me so far?
So solve it for t less
than 0, the answer
is 0 because there was no input.
It started at rest.
Solve it for t bigger than 0.
That means the input is 1.
So you can get some answer
for t bigger than 0.
Paste the two solutions together
by using step functions.
Put the total answer back into
the differential equation.
That total answer
better have the property
that it solves the differential
equation for all time.
OK.
Nod your head yes.
It will make me feel like
I'm doing a fantastic job.
The only trick there
is thinking about how
do you do things like
differentiating unit step
function.
But the derivative of
a unit step function
is delta function.
The derivative of
one of these things,
which looks like a
product of something that
exists for all time and
something that turns on at 0,
it's just a product rule.
Derivative of the
first times the second,
plus second times the
derivative of the first.
Except I said the
same thing twice.
OK.
And so if you do
that, you end up
finding out that to match
the delta functions and the u
functions, it places additional
constraints on the constants
and the answer looks like this.
OK, everybody sort of
sees what I'm saying?
Here's a different
way you can do it.
You could think systems.
So on the chart I told you what
the unit's impulse response
was.
It's 1 over tau u to the
minus t over tau u of t.
So you could use that to
figure out the response.
If I know that delta
goes into a system,
it gives me the unit
impulse response h of t.
And the question then is,
find the unit step response.
Well, there's an easy way
to find the unit step.
That's just the integral
of the unit impulse.
So apparently, the unit
step response of this thing
is the same as the
unit impulse response
of this combined system.
But we know from our
analysis of systems
that you're allowed
to commute things.
So that means I can
flip this order.
Which means then
that all I need to do
is integrate the impulse
response of this thing, which
I knew by assumption.
So if I integrate
the impulse response,
I get the step response.
That's another way of doing it.
I could do it by
Laplace transforms,
I could do it a
gazillion ways, right.
Easy.
You should go home and make
sure you can do all of those.
OK, so the answer
then was number two.
It's this thing.
It's the first order
response, like we said.
It has to go to a particular
final value, which
is equal to the final
value of the input.
There's a variety of ways
that you could get that.
OK, the point of today then
is to take that unit sample
response and figure out
ways to approximate it.
What I want to do
is think about how
I would make a discrete
representation for the CT
system, the leaky tank system.
You've done this in homework.
This was homework one.
I'm trying to do is get some
new perspective by thinking
about all those representations
that we have on the answer
that you already
derived in homework one.
So if I wanted to represent this
system, the leaky tank system,
by a difference
equation, one way
to get the difference
equation is
to make an approximation
to the derivative based
on differences.
The easiest way to
do that is something
that we will call the
forward Euler method.
In the forward Euler
method, what we do is
we think about all
the functions of time.
Say we have an x
function of time
and a y function of time,
the input and the output.
I've got the continuous version
and the discrete version,
that's the sub c and the sub d.
The way I could
make an association
between discrete and continuous
is by sampling the signals.
So I could say that
if I knew x sub
c of t, that's going to
be some squirrely function
but I don't know the answer,
I don't know what that is.
But whatever it is, I will
say that the discrete version
at time n is the same as the
continuous version at time n
times t. t is a
sampling interval.
And the discrete version of
this y function, this output
function, at time
m plus 1t is the m
plus 1 sample of the
discretized output signal.
Then the trick to solving
the differential equation--
remember the differential
equation looked
like tau y dot of t is
x of t minus y of t.
I need to have a way of
thinking about this y dot thing.
A way of thinking
about the y dot thing
would be the slope of
the line that connects
this sample to the next sample.
We call it forward
Euler because at time n
we approximate the derivative
at time n by looking forward.
So we approximate the derivative
of y continuous at time nt
by looking forward, yd of n
plus 1 minus yd of n over t.
Then all we need to do
is make that substitution
into the differential
equation and it turns it
into a difference equation.
So if I make the
substitution that y dot is
given by this kind
of an expression,
substitute into this expression.
I get a difference equation
that is in some sense
equivalent to the original
differential equation.
I can solve that
difference equation
and I get that bottom
difference relationship.
That's what you did
in homework one.
If you were to plot that answer,
here's what you would get.
The blue curve
represents the solution
to the leaky tank problem,
the continuous problem.
1 minus e to the minus t
over tau, quantity u of t.
So that's the blue line.
If you select the
sampling interval
to be small compared to tau--
tau was the time constant
for the CT system--
if you select the sampling
interval to be small,
0.1, the samples
that you calculate
fall right on top of the line.
Great.
That's what we
would want, right.
We're trying to make
a DT approximation.
If our approximation worked the
solution to the DT equations
should be the same,
in some sense,
as the solution to
the CT equations.
But if you change
capital T, you get
something that
looks decreasingly
like the continuous
version if you make T step
bigger and bigger per time.
T is a sampling interval.
If I started with a
small sampling interval,
I got a good approximation.
By the time I get the
sampling interval up to 2T,
this solution to the DT
problem looks nothing
like the solution
to the CT problem.
OK, that's a general problem
in a numerical method.
So what we're
really talking about
is analysis of
numerical methods.
What went wrong?
Why is it that the approximation
worked well and didn't
work well?
I mean, it's intuitively
clear that that's
what you should
have done but we'd
like to be a little
more formal and we'd
more quantitative.
What was it that went wrong?
So to get some
insight let's figure
out the pole for the DT system.
Where's the pole?
OK, where's the pole?
Where is the pole
of the DT system?
Not a large voter
turnout, but 100%
among those who turned out.
So the answer is number two.
It's pretty simple to see
how that would be the answer
if you start with the
difference equation.
It's very simple to
write as e transform.
This evaluate y at m plus 1
is the reverse of a delay,
it's an advance.
Delay is multiplied by
z minus 1, so advance
is multiplied by z.
So you can take the z transform
of the difference equation
to derive the z transform
of the system function.
And then clearly
there a pole here at z
equals 1 minus T over tau.
So the answer was number two.
And it gives us a way to
think about why the difference
solution didn't work well.
What we can see is that
even though you remember--
what was the pole
of the CT system?
What's was the pole
How do you think about
the pole of a CT system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Close.
What's the pole
of the CT system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Minus 1 over tau.
So we would do the same sort of
thing, but now with a Laplace
transform, right.
So we would say
that we could write
Laplace transform of this.
This would be s
tau y is x minus y.
And the pole that we
get in the s plane it's
going to be 1 over 1
minus, minus 1 over tau.
Despite the fact that
the pole in the s plane
was the same for
all the simulations,
the simulations, the discrete
versions, look different.
And that's because the pole for
the DT system is not the same.
The pole for the DT system
depended both on tau,
as did the pole
for the CT system.
But the DT system the pole
depended also on capital T.
So we said that the pole,
you remember the solution
to the last problem, the pole
was at 1 minus T over tau.
So if T over tau is
0.1, the pole is at 0.9.
If T over tau is
0.3, the pole is 0.7.
If the pole is at 2, it's
1 minus 2 is minus 1.
So the pole for the DT system
depends on both T and tau.
And it's given formally
by this relationship.
The equivalent pole in the DT
system is 1 minus T over tau.
So the pole in the CT
system was minus 1 over tau.
The pole in the DT system moved.
The amazing thing is
that the correspondence
between where the pole
in the CT system was
and where the pole
in the DT system is,
is completely determined by
the forward Euler method.
It has nothing to do with
the particular problem.
OK.
We just figured out the
map between the pole
in the s domain and the
pole in the z domain
for a particular problem
for the leaky tank.
It turns out that that same map
holds for every differential
equation.
So what I want to
think about now
is how you would prove
such a statement.
So, think about regardless
of the CT system
that we're thinking
about, I can always
write it in block diagram
form with adders, integrators,
and gains.
So for the leaky tank
system that was easy.
My system looked like--
I had 1 over tau, integrate add.
So my system for the leaky
tank system looked like that.
So the point is that
there there's an A there.
The Euler forward
relationship is telling me
how I can figure out a DT
representation for the A
function.
So let's think about what A is.
A is a thing that in
CT, if the output of A
is y, what's the input to A?
AUDIENCE: The derivative.
PROFESSOR: It's the derivative.
So the input we would
want to call y dot.
So I might say that's x.
So if the input is x, which is y
dot, I put it through and A box
and it comes out y.
So what's the Euler
forward rule saying?
So the Euler forward
rule says that if I
want to compute x of n,
the n sample of this thing,
I should do y dot.
But y dot, I'm doing Euler
forward I should look ahead.
So I should compute y dot
as y of n plus 1 minus y
of n, divide by t.
OK.
Now if I want to make a
DT equivalent system what
I'd like to have is some kind
of a box that I could put x of n
in and get y of n out.
If I had such a box then I could
replace every A in my CT block
diagram with this new box
that depends only on delays.
So let's think about what
would be in that box.
If I wanted to make
w of n out of x of n
according to this
rule, what would I do?
Well, let see, y of n
plus 1 should be y of n
added to T x of n.
So if I want to
compute y of n plus 1.
Oh dear, what's y of n plus 1.
How do I generate-- my
output I want to be y of n.
Where's y of n plus 1?
If I knew y of n, how I
compute y of n plus 1?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It would be back one.
So if I had an R here, what
would be the name of this guy?
This would be y of
n plus 1, right?
Delays have the property
that their output is minus 1.
I need a signal that's plus 1.
So I need the reverse
of a delay, which
I can implement by having this y
signal being generated by an R.
Then this equation says that in
order to compute y of n plus 1,
this thing, what I need
to do is add this to that.
So I need to add this to that.
OK.
The Euler forward
rule says, if I
want to make a
discrete approximation
to the relationship between y
at the output and its derivative
at the input, I should
make one of those boxes.
OK.
I have a rule now.
Regardless of my CT system,
I'll take every integrator
and stick one of those in it.
And what I'll have is a DT
approximation to my CT system
that's everywhere based
on the Euler forward rule.
Is that clear?
So now I have a rule for
converting an arbitrary CT
system into an
equivalent DT system.
Equivalent in the
sense of Euler forward.
And I know that that
transformation will hold.
But it's even better than that.
Because I can now say something
about the relationship
between the position of
the pole in the CT system
and the position of the
pole in the DT system.
Because I know this
original system, the A,
I'm going to think of
A as being 1 over 2.
That's the Laplace
transformation.
And I want that
to be equivalent,
according to this map, to
some transformation in z.
So I can look at
this thing and I
can see well, that
system function,
if I represent that whole
block by a system function,
the system transformation
it looks like that.
But R, that's the
same as 1 over z.
But that's the same
as T over z minus 1.
Apparently, there's a
relationship between s and z.
In fact, z minus 1 is
sT. z is 1 plus sT.
Regardless of what CT
system I started with,
if I use the Euler forward
relationship to make
an approximation
of the integrator
the resulting transformation
will always have that property.
That's exactly what
we saw over here.
So we think about the A's in
the original system being mapped
to something that's a little bit
more complicated, showed here.
But it's a DT representation.
And that DT
representation always
has this property, that
wherever the poles were in s
I can find where the poles
were in z by taking z
equals 1 plus sT.
That's how we get the dependence
on T. If the original pole was
like over here at
minus 1 over tau,
we just put s equals
and we get precisely
this relationship
that we got before.
The 1 plus sT, which
is what I found here,
is the same as the
1 minus T over tau
that we found for the particular
example of the leaky tank.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think you
mentioned this earlier,
but this is purely
because of the mechanics
of the forward Euler method?
PROFESSOR: Because
of forward Euler.
This is only true if I decide
that all of my integrators
are approximated using
the forward Euler rule.
It's absolutely true.
OK.
And that's a very interesting
result. What it says
is that if I think about how
were the poles distributed
in the s plane, I
just used that rule
to figure out how they'll be
distributed in the z plane.
The rule says take the s plane
pole, scale it by capital T,
and then shift the answer by 1.
Well, that's pretty interesting.
Because that means
that there are s's
over here that when
I go through that map
end up outside the unit circle.
That's exactly what I found.
That transformation
has the property
that it can map a stable
CT system, a perfectly
well-behaved CT system,
into an oscillatory or even
a growing divergent DT system.
And you can see that
simply because of the map
between z and s.
Had s been some
number over here,
the unit impulse
response of the CT system
would have been
completely well-behaved,
e to the minus sT. But the
response to the DT equivalent
would be badly behaved
because it would have
mapped outside the unit circle.
OK?
And as you motivated,
the that's only true
because I did Euler forward.
I can do precisely the same
analysis for backward Euler.
Instead of approximating
derivatives
by looking forward in
time like I did before,
I could instead look
backward in time.
If I look backward in time
it looks almost the same.
Now I say the
derivative at the time n
cap T is n minus n minus 1.
Look backwards.
Seems like a trivial difference.
But in fact the answer comes
out completely different.
If I look backwards
in time instead,
what I can think about
now is replacing every one
of these A operators again.
So I think about A. A was
this thing that y came out of
and y dot must have
gone into, which was x.
And now I'm using
Euler backward instead.
So now I want x of n should
look backwards in time.
So I want y of n minus y
of n minus 1 divided by T.
So what this says is that
I want to take y of n
should be y of n minus 1,
added to T times x of n.
So that's a system that
if I started with x of n
and I wanted to
generate y of n, it's
almost the same
as the other one.
Except now it says, when I
want to construct y of n,
start with a delayed
version of y.
How do I get a
delayed version of y?
Delay it.
So I take y and I
delay it like that.
What comes out here
is y of n minus 1.
And then y of n is y of n minus
1, added to T times x of n.
So it's like that.
It's almost the same, but
the math is different.
So now I'm replacing my
A's, which are always 1
over s, with a system that looks
like T going forward divided
by 1 minus R in the bottom.
So that's T over
1 minus 1 over z.
So that's zT over z minus 1.
So that means that z
minus 1 now is sTz.
Cross multiplying 1
minus sT on z is 1.
So z is 1 over 1 minus sT.
I got something that looks
completely different.
This is backward Euler.
This is forward Euler.
So the answer for
forward Euler over here
is 1 plus sT. The answer for
backward Euler is 1 over 1
minus sT. Everybody with me?
So now when I think about
where do the poles land,
if I make the backwards
Euler approximation
they fall on this relationship
instead of the previous.
And the interesting thing
about that relationship
is that if you
think about the way
this works every point in
the left half plane of s,
according to this map, ends
up inside a little circle
in the z domain.
The entire left half
plane maps into the circle
that's shaded in the right.
If you just make a picture.
If you just plug in s equals
1, where does s happen?
Plug in s equals minus
1, where's the new z?
Plug in s equals 1 over
T, where's the new z?
All of the values in the
left half plane for s
map inside a small
circle in the z plane.
Which means that if the original
system had a pole anywhere
in the left half plane--
remember left half
planes, left-sided.
We're thinking that those
are the kinds of systems
whose unit impulse
responses converge toward 0.
If you had a system that had
poles in the left half plane
and you do the backwards
Euler transformation,
you're guaranteed to
get a system that has
poles inside the unit circle.
In fact, they're in a smaller
circle than the unit circle.
OK.
Everybody sort of know
what I'm talking about?
So this is the idea
of thinking about,
not relationships among
DT representations,
or representations
among CT systems,
but relations between CT and DT.
It's because we can cast each
of those kinds of systems
into a polynomial
representation that we
can make a correspondence
between the CT system
and the DT approximation.
I'll talk about just
one more, and that's
the trapezoid rule, which is
what you did in homework two.
You may remember
homework two, right.
Since it was due,
like, yesterday.
So the last problem
in homework two
had to do with finding a
numerical approximation
to the mass and springs system.
And you remember, we
did three of them.
Those three were actually
forward Euler, backward Euler,
and trapezoidal rule.
Trapezoidal rule
says, OK, I didn't
like this idea of
looking forward,
that seems anti-symmetric.
What's special about
forwards or backwards?
That's also treating
backwards special.
I want to treat it
symmetric in time.
That's what the center
difference approximation did.
The center difference
approximation in homework two
was based on a trapezoidal rule.
The trapezoidal
rule says, OK, let
me approximate my DT output.
Let me think about a sequence of
samples in a DT output, y to n.
Let me force the
differential equation
to be true at every
point between samples.
In the forward Euler
and the backward,
we force the
differential equation
to be true at integers n.
That made us compute
derivatives by looking
forward or backwards.
In a trapezoidal rule we force
the differential equation
to be true between samples.
Then we say, OK, the
signal yc should be
the average of those samples.
And the derivative
should be the difference
of the two samples divided
by T. So they're centered.
Everybody see that?
So we're going to force
the differential equation
to be true at points between
the samples of the difference
equation.
And that's going to give me a
different kind of relationship
that looks strikingly
the same as these kinds
of relationships.
OK, so now I'm going to say
that I would like to have
A, which maps y, y dot is x.
Except now what I'm going
to want to say is that x--
which I will represent
as the average
of the nth and nth minus 1--
should be constrained to be
the derivative of this guy,
which I will do by looking at
the corresponding values of y.
OK?
So that gives me a different
way of doing the approximation.
I get y of n should be y of n
minus 1, plus T over 2, x of n
plus x of n minus 1.
Just a different rule for how
to do the derivative, that's
all I've done.
But it gives me a
different kind of a system.
Now I want to have x of n
go into something that I
will make my new A boxes.
To compute y of n I should
have a delayed version.
Well, that's easy.
I make one of those.
And y of n should be the
sum of the delayed version.
And T over 2 times a
delayed version of x.
So I have to do this.
So now I have the sum of x
and a delayed version of x.
And I put that through T over 2.
So here is my new
discrete approximation
to the accumulator.
And I do just the same
thing I did before.
I say, what's the
relationship between s and z?
So my A, which is
the same as 1 over s,
now becomes that block diagram,
which looks like T over 2.
Looks like r plus 1.
Let's see, 1 plus R.
Lets do it the other way.
So T over 2, 1
plus R, 1 minus 2.
So T over 2 from here, 1
plus R from here, 1 over 1
minus R from there.
Which I can convert into
z and I'll get T over 2,
z plus 1 over z minus 1.
I don't think I made
any mistakes yet.
So then I get z plus 1--
z minus 1.
Bring that over there,
bring that over there.
sT over 2, z plus 1.
Now bring the z's over here.
1 minus sT over 2 operate on
z to give me 1 plus sT over 2.
So z is 1 plus sT over 2,
over 1 minus sT over 2.
So that's my new transformation
based on the trapezoidal rule,
which is showed here.
Hopefully they match.
So z maps to 1 plus sT over 2
divided by 1 minus sT over 2.
And the interesting thing
about that transformation
is that it map the entire
left half plane of s
precisely into the unit circle.
That was the reason that
the trapezoidal rule
worked so much better
on the problems
you tried in homework two.
So if the pole starts
out being real so
that it's someplace in the
s plane on this red arrow.
Euler forward gave us
a pole in the z plane
that could be, if T is big
enough, outside the unit
circle.
In the Euler backwards
method, it always
lands someplace in
the unit circle.
In the trapezoidal rule it lands
someplace in the unit circle.
But in the mass spring
problem and the poles
were on the
imaginary axis, which
means that in the
Euler forward method,
the poles went outside
the unit circle.
That's the reason the solution
to the mass spring problem
diverged.
In the Euler backward
method, the poles
that were on the j omega
axis mapped to the perimeter
of this inside circle.
That's why they converged,
even though the mass spring
system should have isolated
forever in the solution
that you did with
Euler backwards.
It converged, and that's
because the method maps
poles on the j omega axis
inside the unit circle.
That's not what we want.
What we want for the mass
spring system is to map
the j omega poles directly
onto the unit circle
so that pure
oscillations over here
correspond to pure
oscillations over there.
And that's exactly what
the trapezoidal rules does.
OK, so the point then--
and this was the solution
to that homework problem.
So the point is
that not only are we
interested in figuring
out relationships
among the different
representations for CT systems
and among the different
representations for DT systems,
there's a lot of insight
that you can get especially
into things like
numerical approximations
by thinking about how the
relationships in one domain
map to the other.